hey guys Pete here today I'm going to do
another character profile from one of my
favorite characters major garland Briggs
he was a super interesting character in
the original run we found out a lot more
about him in the secret history of Twin
Peaks and he's turning out to be a big
player in season 3 as well this will
contain spoilers of everything that
major garland Briggs has ever been
involved in so if you're not caught up
through part 9 of the return or you
don't want book spoilers from the secret
history then you're going to want to
stop watching now so major Briggs was
one of my favorites because he seemed
kind of insignificant compared to some
of the more zany characters but as
season 1 and 2 progressed he just kept
showing up at important time and it was
clear that he was involved in something
but you never really knew what we did
know about him was that he was in the
United States Air Force and that he did
some work near Twin Peaks but he always
said that was classified when anybody
asked when the secret history came out
we found out that he was actually the
overseer of Project Blue Book which was
a top-secret program that revolves
around paranormal activity and we found
out that it wasn't just like
extraterrestrial wasn't just involving
things from outer space but this
particular work that he was doing also
focused in on the local area around 20
Peaks so some of the major things that
happened to him in the original run were
that he disappeared for two days in the
woods outside of Twin Peaks while he was
with Cooper we all remember that and he
returned a couple days later saying that
he had been taken to the White Lodge
later on when the Earl who was an ex-fbi
agent who was very interested in these
lodges kidnapped him and held him
hostage in his cabin for a period of
time the Wyndham was more interested in
the Black Lodge at the end of season 2
he's able to escape with the help of Leo
but after that he ends up meeting with a
Cooper but he realizes that there's
something wrong with him in relation to
his trip into the Red Room the story
from there was that he disappeared that
he died in a fire at his workplace but
we found out just recently that he did
not die he actually disappeared and his
body showed up without a head in South
Dakota 25 years later
so the backstory on major Briggs was he
was an Air Force guy he ended up in Twin
Peaks on a transfer in the secret
history we learned out that he was
handpicked by douglas milford dougie
milford who had been working with
richard nixon to keep project Bluebook
going as a secret operation he
hand-picked him he liked him because he
thought he was a solid officer that
would keep up his work basically you
know what I mean and we saw that time
and time again with major breaks
throughout the early seasons of 20 that
he was very no-nonsense and that he was
also very competent and self-assured and
what he did we also learned that he was
picked by a Milford to compile the
dossier or to continue the work on the
dossier that is the subject of the
secret history of Twin Peaks and that is
basically a book of documents that keeps
track of all the mysteries around Twin
Peaks
he was also Bobby Berg this father bobby
was a much more central character to the
story as far as we saw when watching and
his wife Betty also seemed to be a
straight shooter and we just saw her
return in part 9 if you remember at the
very beginning of things Sarah Palmer
had called Betty to check and see if
Laura was with Bobby because they were
boyfriend and girlfriend and that was on
the morning before they got the call
that Laura had been found dead after the
murder Briggs had concerned for her son
and the direction his life was headed so
we had a lot of these scenes where he
tried to offer to talk to him there was
also one where he got frustrated with
him because he lit a cigarette at the
table and Briggs slapped him and this
goes on for a while
until one day they're at the Double R
and they you know he tells him about
this vision that he had of a grand home
and Bobby coming to visit him and the
son happily embracing the father and the
family also did a family session with
dr. Jacoby that we saw where Bobby what
really wasn't into it but yeah we saw
that he was a good father he was
frustrated with his son but he also was
very open to making it a better
situation the next thing that happened
with him that really is where I really
started to get interested in his
character was when the log lady came and
sat next to him at the Double R and I
believe this was just after not not the
same day but just after he told Bobby
about the vision she tells him that the
log has something to tell him but he
can't hear it
so she delivers or translates the logs
message which is delivered the message
and yeah this is where he got
interesting for me because he didn't
seem unsettled at all and actually just
seemed to understand what the log was
saying so he then went and visited
Cooper at the Great Northern and this is
when he showed him those printouts at
the time we thought these were from deep
space and that they were picked up
around the time that Cooper had been
shot
the first message said the Owls are not
what they seem and it was just in with
the jumble of numbers and things so it
stood out obviously and there was also
another one that called out Cooper by
name and we just saw this come back in
in season three major Briggs also told
the guys after Leland's death that there
was much more Han than they could handle
and then he made plans with Cooper to go
fishing after Leland funeral while they
were there they talked about different
things like Cooper suspension about the
nature of Bob and he also made mention
of the white lodge Cooper got up to go
to the bathroom and at that moment a
bright light came out of nowhere
and basically Briggs disappeared two
days later he just showed back up in his
house
wearing an old aviators outfit Bobby and
his wife were there he gave her a hug
and he told her things were not exactly
alright
during his disappearance he picked up a
three triangle marking or tattoo kind of
thing behind his ear but we'll talk
about that the minute after his return
he told the sheriff agent Cooper and doc
Hayward about some of the things that
happened while he was gone he mentioned
a giant owl sheriff Truman asked him
about his work again and he sort of
instinctually said that it was
classified but then he decided this was
too important so he told them that he
was involved with the Air Force's
Project Blue Book even though it was
officially dissolved in 1969 and that he
was still working on it and he was still
searching for a place called the White
Lodge
Dougy Milford then dies or at least in
the timeline major breaks find out about
his death so he goes back to listening
post alpha which is the name of the
station that they had devised and put
together for listening to all the
different things in deep space and
around Twin Peaks and he realized that
he had one more message from Milford
this was actually written on the night
that he disappeared into the White Lodge
in the yeah the secret history find out
that Milford had some regrets about
things that had happened over the years
but he urged Briggs to continue and
tells him to keep up the work and wait
until his next controller arrives on the
show the day after that he stumbles into
the Sheriff's Department he tells them
that he had some concerns about the Air
Force and the reaction to what happened
to him when he disappeared and he made a
prediction that there was going to be
great trouble and he says that he
doesn't think the Air Force has pure
reasons for searching for the White
Lodge at the double are a couple days
later the log lady comes over and
examined his markings and they went to
the sheriff's department together to
talk to agent Cooper where they both
show him the mark
that they have as mentioned brig has the
three triangles which is similar to what
dougie Milford had from his
disappearance in the woods by twin peaks
when he was a kid but the log ladies are
different she has the two peaks from her
experience of being abducted or her
disappearance in you know in the same
time when she was a child remember she
was with Col rod and one other person
and they were basically abducted we'll
say so a few days after that in the show
we find out that major Briggs has seen
the petroglyph from Al Cave and at the
same time we find out agent Cooper needs
major breaks his health in relation to
Windom Earle it turns out that when the
murrow's was involved with Project Blue
Book at one time and even though the
security clearance had been cleared and
all that he still says that is since
there's going to be human lives at stake
that he'll go ahead and tell them what
he knows he also tells coop that he's
seen the petroglyph before he ends up
telling sheriff Truman and coop about
Earl's involvement with Project Blue
Book he says that when the merle was
became obsessed once the investigation
focused around the woods surrounding
Twin Peaks and was removed from the
project after he became violent he also
showed them some footage of Earl talking
about this evil place called the Black
Lodge by the dug pause later on major
Briggs is walking through the woods and
he sees what looks like two men in a
horse costume we find out that one of
them's Windom Earle and he fired a
tranquilizer dart into Briggs and you
know knocked him out this is how he
ended up in the cabin Earl asked him
about the symbol at Al Cave major break
doesn't want to cooperate of course but
then he gets a injection of a truth
serum from Windham Earl and he tells him
that he first saw the petroglyph at Al
Cave in a dream and the meaning behind
the symbols were that there's a time
where Jupiter and Saturn meet they will
receive you he then says some backwards
talk that we can you know we found out
later on is that gum you like is coming
back in style that gum you like
he woke up the next day and Leo fries
him telling him to go safe Shelly he
gets up and leaves but he's been dosed
with haloperidol which is a really
strong tranquilizer so he eventually
makes it back to the sheriff's
department but he can't really answer
any questions while he's rambling he
says protect the Queen and fear and love
opened the doors obviously the second
thing a fear and love opens the doors
refers to the lodges the next day he
gets back to normal and he has breakfast
with his wife at the diner and Sarah
Palmer comes in with dr. Jacoby and
there's this strange little thing where
she tells him I'm in the Black Lodge
with Dale Cooper in a man's voice now
people have broken that down and it's
supposedly Windom Earle Windom Earles
voice in the beginning but that's all I
really know about it so leading up to
his death and where we're at currently
in the show because of that
communication with Cooper's name and
other things like Gordon Cole's
involvement major Briggs basically came
to believe that Cooper was the person
that was sent to continue his and
Milford's work afterwards so as soon as
evil Cooper got out of the lodge he went
to see major Briggs and even though he
probably didn't know it at first he
eventually realizes that there's
something wrong that this is actually
well whether he knew was a doppelganger
or not isn't clear but he knew that
something was wrong with Cooper and that
made him worry that he might have
misunderstood what Milford was trying to
say directly after that as far as I can
tell Briggs wrote a message for Bobby
that would be delivered through his wife
to visit a location near listening post
alpha at 2:53 on October 1st and October
2nd and to put some soil into his pocket
before he leaves this place called jack
rabbits palace so that was put into the
metal capsule we just saw and into the
living room chair and Betty his wife was
told directly that Hawk sheriff Truman
and Bobby would eventually come asking
about what
happen with his meeting when he met with
Dale Cooper after he returned from the
Red Room after that from what we know he
went to listening post alpha by himself
intending to send the made a signal and
we see that in the secret history that
the Mayday protocol or Mayday whatever
you want to call it is been set into
motion after that he was reported to
have died in a fire at the station and
from Hawk and Truman talking about this
we know that Cooper left town soon after
we don't know exactly what happened up
there during the fire if he did this to
throw evil Cooper off himself
or something else happened we just don't
really know but we do know that over the
next 25 years that his fingerprints
showed up in like 16 different locations
or 16 different requests that came
against that military block that we saw
happen in Buckhorn South Dakota we also
know from William Hastings that he was
hibernating in a different reality or a
different dimension which you know
Hastings calls his own so in September
Hastings and his partner Ruth who are
researching this stuff claimed that they
visited the zone where they met the
major we know that the major they're
speaking about is major garland Briggs
because he identifies him in the lineup
the Tammi shows him he said that he
needed coordinates and he needed them to
access a secure military database and
when they did so Bill and Ruth watched
as the man floated up into the air and
said the words Cooper Cooper and then
his head disappeared then something
happened that we're not exactly sure
about but there were other people there
who attacked them wanted to know
Hastings wife's name and eventually
killed Bruce the next thing Hastings
remember is he awoke at home and knew
that Ruth was dead
so in buckhorn later on Ruth severed
head was discovered in her bed along
with Briggs's body which had no head
both bodies were said to have died
within the last week but the big mystery
with major Briggs was is that his body
was the same age as of
was before he disappeared 25 years ago
also he had in his stomach the wedding
ring of dougie Jones the next and last
appearance that major Briggs made in
Twin Peaks was when major coupe was
passing through the mod zone we saw his
head float below him and the void and he
just says blue rose so that is pretty
much everything that that major breaks
has been involved with and it's a pretty
amazing thing when you look at it like
that what's going to happen to
Jackrabbit palace we don't know but it's
fascinating that he put this in if you
think about it in the timeline he you
know that he did this back then it's
also fascinating that all the stuff with
Bobby and Bobby being rebellious and
upset and becoming a cop and being there
it's it's fascinating that his father
saw this all before he disappeared so
you know I've been thinking about it
because I made the character profile of
Jeffries last week thinking about these
are the tube characters that were
definitely involved with the lodges like
in visiting that we know went and came
back of course Jeffries only came back
for a short time but both of these
characters even though the actors who
played them have passed on are playing a
major part in season 3 so far so I
wanted to put all the information about
Briggs out there I think we're going to
find out a lot more if you want to know
more about this listening post alpha and
things like that watch my secret history
video because I go into it more deeply
there and I don't know I love this guy I
loved him he creeped in I like that
about him he became more important as
things progressed and he was an enigma
you know he was a really cool guy and I
just found myself keying in on him more
and more with each rewatch of the
original series so it's definitely a
tragedy that Donna's Davis wasn't able
to reprise his role but I think it's a
testament to how great of an actor he
was and how great of a character mark
frost and David Lynch made up with this
guy that we can still feel like his
presence is there even after he passed
away
so I hope you liked the video please
give it a like please subscribe to my
channel follow me on my social media
accounts I'm on Twitter all the time I
try to post in the other ones as well so
give me a follow give me some support
out there and I can't wait for part 10
you know I'll be doing my videos this
week so thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon